welcome to the David packman show I am
Farren cousins from Ring of Fire sitting
in for David packman today and man do we
have a great show coming up for you
we've gotten more potential charges that
could be filed against Donald Trump
we've got Jim Jordan getting smacked
down by Manhattan district attorney
Alvin Bragg we've got Maga freaks coming
out in droves to attack former Trump
lawyer Jenna Ellis all that and much
much more is coming up so let's jump
right into it as I mentioned
there could be a new Avenue for Jack
Smith the special prosecutor with the
doj to charge Trump with even more
crimes than previously thought thanks to
a ruling last week a three-judge panel
actually overturned a lower court judge
Carl Nichols Who was appointed by Trump
uh Nichols had ruled that prosecutors
trying the capital rioters could not
charge those individuals with
obstructing an official Congressional
proceeding
the official proceeding of course being
the certification of the Electoral
College votes and for some reason judge
Nichols said nope even though they very
obviously obstructed and postponed that
hearing through their actions
you can't charge them with that
so then late last week a three-judge
panel voted two to one that yeah
yeah you can charge these individuals
with obstructing an official
Congressional proceeding
now what's important about that
according to former assistant Manhattan
district attorney Andrew Weissman is
that now that this three-judge panel
has given permission for prosecutors to
use that obstruction charge Weissman
says that Jack Smith could now with that
permission
file those same charges potentially
against Donald Trump let me read you
what Weissman had to say during an
appearance on msnbc's Morning Joe
this is really a gift for Jack Smith
because as good as it is for the
Washington D.C prosecutors who have
hundreds of pending cases who want to
know that this is a charge they can
continue charging Jack Smith is going to
be thinking about this obstruction
charge with respect to the former
president
there's nothing better for Jack Smith
than to know that this has already been
approved by the DC circuit meaning he
can charge it and unless the Supreme
Court disagrees with the D.C circuit he
knows that this is a rock solid legally
a legal Rock Solid charge that he has to
prove it factually but getting the sort
of pre-clearance is unusual to have and
he has to be happy that the Court ruled
that this is a charge that will stick
for any potential charge he is thinking
with respect to the former president
a lot to take in right let me distill
that down to its most basic components
obviously the first thing you have is
the United States Supreme Court it's
likely this will obviously be challenged
and head to the U.S Supreme Court at
which point the justices
most likely given the magnitude of this
uh you know charge I don't think they'll
take it up
I think they'll look at that three-judge
panel ruling two to one vote and
basically come to the decision we don't
want to wade into this
if they come to that decision they will
say nope we are not taking the case the
DC circuits decision stand that clears
the way for Jack Smith of course to hit
Trump with these obstruction charges if
they choose to take it up God only knows
how that's going to end up right we have
seen this court absolutely railroad
legal precedent
we don't know
so there's a big question mark over that
so 50 50 chance they take it up then if
they take it up 50 50 chance there that
they rule that yes you can charge these
individuals so let's assume for a moment
the Jack Smith gets the clearance the
Supreme Court either doesn't take it up
or rules in favor of the DC circuit and
Smith can charge Donald Trump with
obstruction of an official proceeding
that's a relatively minor charge
compared to obviously everything else
that Jack Smith is investigating so if
Smith moves forward and decides to
charge Donald Trump with obstruction
it's going to be a very minor charge on
top of everything else that he could
potentially be charging him with so it's
basically a way to just kind of pad
everything a little bit more
but I don't think that's where Jack
Smith is really wanting to put all of
his chips
because to me what I'm reading into this
is that if you can charge any of these
people involved in the events of January
6th with obstructing an official
government proceeding
that is something that Jack Smith can
then use as a bargaining chip
against any of the individuals who may
not want to cooperate fully with the
investigation maybe we want to plead the
fifth maybe we we don't want to come
talk to you maybe we want to challenge
these subpoenas of course we've seen all
this happen so far to no avail on the
part of most of the people that have
been subpoenaed
but this would give Jack Smith a really
great bargaining chip because it's a
fairly simple and easy charge to prove
and it's also something that most
prosecutors would not want to waste
their time pursuing
but if he can take that and dangle that
potential charge in front of any witness
that may not want to fully cooperate and
say listen
you don't have to tell me everything you
can plead the fifth if you want but I
just want you to know that here in my
back pocket
I have obstructing an official
government proceeding and I can charge
you with this it's very obvious that
your involvement on that particular day
led to the postponement of that
Electoral College vote and that is
illegal
so
I don't want to hit you with these
charges
but I'm more than willing to do it if
you do not cooperate
now some people may hear that and think
wow that kind of seems a little a little
underheaded but trust me it's not things
like this happen all the time in
criminal prosecutions and investigations
across the country every day
when you can find those little smaller
charges you know the obstructing
government proceeding obstruction of
justice by the way is usually the
bargaining chip that prosecutors will
use
to get people to testify and come
forward with information basically
offering an immunity deal right like I'm
not going to charge you with this as
long as you give me all of this
it is very common and to me that kind of
seems like the most likely Avenue that
Jack Smith would pursue if he gets the
clearance to bring those charges
that's not to say that he's not going to
go ahead and Tack that on to Donald
Trump because I do believe that's
something you could do just to you know
stretch out whatever else you got why
not hit him with everything and that is
probably what would happen if he's able
to do this again it's going to depend on
the Supreme Court that's one of those
wait and see moments that I know none of
us like
but that's where we stand right now
could be a new charge against Donald
Trump could be a bargaining chip either
way the wins at his back right Jack
Smith holds all the cards right now so
let's see what he does with it
but I will say one other thing speaking
of indictments in Donald Trump and
criminal charges and all that new polls
have come out this week multiple new
polls showing that the indictment from
last week is not helping Donald Trump at
all
now shortly after the indictment about a
day or two later Donald Trump got on
Truth social and uh you know attacked
the prosecutors as he's been doing but
he also mentioned in one of those posts
on true socials my poll numbers have
gone through the roof
and to an extent with the Republican
base they absolutely have
but if you're just going to cherry pick
the data then sure you can pretty much
use it to prove whatever you want to
prove so you got to look at the bigger
picture which is something Donald Trump
doesn't want people to do because his
approval rating
ever since those indictments came down
has tanked Four Points dropping from an
already historically low 29 percent
all the way down to 25
according to a new ABC News ipsos poll
but what's more important with this
polling data along with other polling
data that recently came out from CNN
is that Independents are the ones
who have effectively turned against
Donald Trump let me read some of these
numbers for you here
according to the ABC poll 54 of
Independents say that Trump should have
been charged with a crime
57 percent
say that he intentionally did something
illegal
now it is a little weird that those two
numbers are not equal which means you
have more people more independent saying
yes he definitely did something illegal
and he did it illegal on purpose
but you only have 54 that say he should
have been charged so there's a three a
three percent Gap there that makes no
sense so three percent of Independents
think oh yeah he totally intentionally
broke the law but he shouldn't be
charged
so that's a little weird again you would
expect those numbers to match up but
they don't but either way you have a
majority of independent voters and
that's the key that do believe not only
that Trump should have been charged but
that he definitely intentionally did
something illegal
the CNN numbers are even worse for Trump
62 percent of Independents in the CNN
poll approve of the indictment
of course Democrats uh Democrats I don't
know why I said that awkward the
Democrats overwhelmingly support it
Republicans overwhelmingly reject it
so what does this matter right Trump's
approval rating goes down four points
obviously very bad for him as he tries
to run for president
but it's the numbers with the
Independence that are important
because yes Trump's poll numbers within
the Republican Party they're doing great
they're doing better than they have in
the last year
the problem Trump faces is that he
hasn't attracted any new voters
and that's the key
see Trump cannot win a general election
with just his Maga base he can win a
primary with it 100 percent like no
question about that and right now based
on the numbers looks like he may be
cruising to an easy Victory with that
but when it comes time for the general
election
he's repulsed
the independence he's repulsed the
moderate Republicans
right-wing groups have already been
holding focus groups
since the indictments came down
and sure there's plenty of them who say
nope this has actually made me more
likely to vote for Trump but some
Republicans say this sealed the deal I'm
not going to support him
so even the people who came back to
support Trump after saying no I'm done
with him wait no I'm going to come back
those aren't new Trump voters those are
previous Trump voters
who are just coming back into the fold
so they voted for him in the past and
now they're saying they're going to vote
for him again so that doesn't count as a
new gain for Trump that's why these
numbers are important we have to fully
analyze them and realize what they're
telling us and right now they're telling
us that those true moderates The
Independents the swing voters out there
in America
they want nothing to do with this guy
they're sick of it
they're saying he's too caustic
he's too bombastic he's got too much
baggage
I mean he's not due back in court until
December
but under New York state law the
prosecution has to be ready to go to
trial within six months of issuing the
indictments
so even though he's not due back till
December at that point the prosecution
legally has to be ready to go
so we could get a trial during the
Republican primary we could get a trial
before
the 2024 election
and that's not going to play well with
those moderates and independents because
we're also talking about a New York jury
Donald Trump is not well liked up there
so he doesn't stand a very good chance
of being successful maybe on appeal but
probably not with initial trial
and The Independents are already sick of
him they're ready for him to go away his
poll numbers continue to get worse no
matter what he says
he's in trouble and he knows it
we have to take a quick break I am
Farren cousins you can follow me on
Twitter Instagram and Facebook I'm at
fair and balanced and subscribe to the
ring of fire YouTube channel youtube.com
the ring of fire we'll be right back
with more on the David packman show
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
welcome back to the David packman show I
am Farren cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today and if you
happen to like me you can go subscribe
to my YouTube channels youtube.com the
ring of fire and youtube.com
fahrenbalanced now let's move on here I
gotta talk about Jim Jordan right
chairman of the house Judiciary
Committee Jim Jordan has
well he's really stepped in it I mean
he's already in over his head he's got
these weaponization hearings that even
Fox News has said have been a complete
dud
Essie Waters asked a couple weeks ago
where are the Bombshells you've been
having these hearings not just Jim
Jordan but the other Republicans you've
given us nothing
but Jim Jordan is hell-bent on making
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
pay for taking on Donald Trump so this
week
Jim Jordan announced that he and his
Judiciary Committee they're going to
take a little field trip up to New York
City on April 17th
and while they're on their little field
trip they're going to hold what they're
calling a field hearing
to talk about the absolutely out of
control crime rate in Manhattan and
they're gonna of course try to tell us
that Alvin Bragg instead of taking on
the former president needs to be taking
on all these all these darn shoplifters
out here and the muggers and the the
spray painting vandals that's the real
crime in New York City not this
fraudulent business transaction for a
multi-billion dollar Corporation no no
no no no we don't worry about that Alvin
you need to go get the guy trying to
steal Tylenol from Rite Aid as Eric
Trump pointed out about a week ago
so Jim Jordan heading to New York to
tell us how bad crime really is but uh
here's the thing after this was
announced Alvin Bragg's office issued a
statement
that said if chairman Jordan truly cared
about Public Safety he could take a
short drive to Columbus Dayton
Cincinnati Cleveland Akron or Toledo in
his home state instead of using taxpayer
dollars to travel hundreds of miles
this way
now
the reason
that this Aid to Alvin Bragg released
this statement saying hey if you want to
look at crime go look at your home state
go look in your backyard is because as
Business Insider pointed out Columbus
Ohio which has a population of
approximately 907 thousand people closed
out 2022
with 15.4 murders per 100
000 citizens
15.4 murders per 100 000 citizens
New York City on the other hand closed
out 2022 with a murder rate of 5.2
murders per 100 000 citizens now correct
me if I'm wrong but wouldn't that mean
that writing Jim Jordan's backyard the
murder rate is almost three times
the murder rate of New York City
now yeah I mean that that kind of seems
like what that means so Jim Jordan as
Alvin Bragg's office said you you want
to talk about the murder rate you want
to talk about people getting killed out
of control crime
all you have to do is go home
why don't you worry about your own
backyard and not about New York City
now the crime rate
in New York and of course in California
we have heard Republicans talk about
that ad nauseam uh for for over a year
really it was a big big thing in the
lead up to the 2022 midterms then then
they stopped talking about it after the
midterms because I guess crime doesn't
exist once elections are over but now
that Alvin Bragg is Prosecuting Donald
Trump we have had Republicans across the
board not just in Congress I know my
Governor down here in Florida Ron
DeSantis while trashing Alvin Bragg
brought up the crime rate there so y'all
want to talk about crime rates let's
talk about crime rates let's talk about
the fact that in New York City
it is true that property crime has
increased
property crime of course being vandalism
theft burglary things like that
however the murder rate
the violent crime rate that includes
non-murders but other violent crime
assaults of multiple kinds has decreased
now let's take a look at my state of
Florida down here
now in Florida property crime has gone
down in the last few years
so we're not seeing as many burglaries
and muggings and you know vandalism as
they are in New York City
but what has increased by double digits
down here in the State of Florida is the
violent crime rape a rate excuse me so
here in Florida
you're less likely
to have somebody break into your home
and steal your stuff than New York City
but you're more likely to be killed
or beaten to a pulp or maybe sexually
assaulted
but you don't ever hear the media
talking about that do you no what do
they talk about they talk about the
runaway crime rate in New York City in
the blue States well I got news for you
media
the highest crime rates in the country
most of them out of the top 25
take place all down here in the south
was the South have in common folks yeah
we're all red States down here the
highest crime rates in the country are
taking place in red States run with an
iron fist by Republicans
but Republicans don't ever mention that
and the media does such a poor job of
pushing back on these narratives that
blue states are out of control with
crime
that they miss the fact that you're more
likely to be the victim of a crime in a
red State than you are in a blue state
and that's why I love that Bragg's
office has pushed back on Jim Jordan
they've pushed back on him repeatedly
but this is a big one
the murder rate in Jim Jordan's own
District
is far higher than it is in New York
City but Jim Jordan is going to waste
our tax dollars he's going to waste
everybody's time going to New York I
what trying to find victims of violent
crime are you hoping to roam the streets
like a vigilante you know maybe you're
gonna pull a Batman and beat up somebody
trying to take a woman's purse from the
street I don't know what Jim Jordan's
gonna do
but I do know that based on everything
we've seen Jim Jordan do this year
it's probably going to backfire and make
him look like a total idiot
now
I talked about Florida for a moment I
got to talk about something even more
disturbing down here in the state of
Florida
on Monday a Republican state legislator
here in Florida by the name of Webster
Barnaby
during a hearing on a transgender
bathroom bill that will make it a
criminal offense for a transgender
individual to use the bathroom of the
gender that they identify as
Mr Barnaby
went on a bigoted disgusting tirade
against transgender people so we have
the clip of it here he is again this man
is Webster Barnaby he is a Republican
state representative here in Florida
take a look I'm looking at
society today
and it's like I'm watching an X-Men
movie
with
people that when you watch the X-Men
movies
for Marvel Comics
it's like we have mutants living among
us on planet Earth
and you know
some people don't like that but that's a
fact we have people that live among us
today on planet Earth
that
are happy to display themselves
as if they were mutants from another
planet
this is the planet Earth
where God created men male and women
female
I'm a proud Christian Conservative
Republican
I'm not on the fence
not on the fence
there is so much darkness in our world
today
so much evil in our world today
and so many people who are afraid to
address the evil the dysphoria the
dysfunction
I'm not afraid to address the dysphoria
or the dysfunction the Lord rebuke you
Satan and all of your demons and all of
your imps who come and parade before us
that's right I called you demons and
imps who come and parade before us
and pretend that you are part of this
world Webster Barnaby Republican
representative here in the state of
Florida
the words that he used
like you're from another planet you're a
mutant you're a demon you're an imp all
of those words are meant to dehumanize
other people
he is dehumanizing taking away their
very personhood
of transgender individuals here in the
State of Florida now of course he issued
an apology oh he's sorry that he said it
no you're not you're absolutely not
sorry that you said it you're sorry that
there's backlash on it you meant every
word you said
you wouldn't have done that you wouldn't
have doubled down on it you wouldn't
have repeated yourself over and over if
you didn't mean it
and I gotta bring up of course too as a
X-Men fan
his invocation of the X-Men there
actually proves that he he doesn't know
anything the whole point of X-Men is
that these individuals are are treated
differently
they are looked down upon by Society
because they are different because they
were born different
and they are the subject of of
prejudices they are the subject of laws
restricting
their very existence
all of that takes place in the X-Men
comics and this guy Webster Barnaby
doesn't have the wherewithal to
understand that he's the bad guy in The
X-Men comics
he's Reverend Striker
and he doesn't even
realize it
but that's who he is sorry it's not
Reverend Striker
but he hates these people because of who
they are
and he's pushing like every other
Republican in the state this bill to ban
transgender people from using public
restrooms of course again completely
ignoring the irony
of saying guess what we're going back to
the days of segregation
these certain people who look a certain
way can't use the same bathroom
have you thought about that folks have
you actually sat down and realized that
we're heading back into the days of
segregation we're not moving past it
we're not learning from our past
mistakes
and Mr Barnaby granted he was born and
raised in in England he only moved to
the United States in 1991 so even though
he was born in 1959 he did an experience
the segregation that was taking place
here in the United States at the time
I'm sure is a naturalized citizen he he
knows about it he had to have studied it
he is aware of what this country once
was and now he's part of the group
trying to take us back to that
for the record I've looked and looked
and looked I cannot find a single
instance
where a transgender person
has been accused of assaulting someone
in a public restroom
do you know why
because they're going in there to use
the bathroom right you're out and about
you're shopping hey I need to go relieve
myself you go in there you do your
business you wash your hands and you
leave
that that's it that's it and we're
saying that that is too much that is too
much of a privilege to extend to
transgender people they're just trying
to exist
they're not out there
breaking laws they're they're not out
there doing anything wrong they're not
coming after us they're not trying to
indoctrinate us they just want to live
and here in Florida and across the
country in red States we're saying no
Your Existence is offensive to me so I
want to oppress you
we have seen this before not just in
American history but in world history
and it never ends well for that group
that is being oppressed
but that oppression is alive and well
here in the State of Florida thanks to
people like Webster Barnaby
uh Barnaby Webster or Webster Barnaby
yeah I had it right anyway we got to
take another break I am fair and cousins
and for David packman you're watching
the David packman show we'll be right
back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am Faron cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David packman and if you
would like even more from me you can
follow me on Twitter Instagram Facebook
and tick tock on all of those platforms
I'm at fair and balanced you can also
follow my YouTube channels youtube.com
fahrenbalanced and of course the big one
youtube.com
the Ring of Fire
let's talk about some of the problems
facing Donald Trump's lawyers and no I'm
not talking about all the issues with
Joe takapina the issues that have come
up with Jim trustee the sanctions that
Alina Haba was hit with no I'm actually
going old school with Trump lawyers
Jenna Ellis the former Trump lawyer who
of course worked on efforts to overturn
the 2020 election for which she was also
punished in Colorado
this week she posted some screenshots
of uh messages that she has received in
messages that she has seen online from
Angry Maga fans
who are angry at her about something
that according to Jenna isn't even
happening
these attacks are disgustingly sexist
and crude but I'm going to read a couple
of them here
um these again these are the ones that
she posted uh first one of course was
from Laura Loomer who according to Raw
Story mocked her for being quote
disowned by Trump World and trying to
ingratiate herself with Ron desantis's
campaign by offering herself up as quote
sloppy seconds
Trump supporter Preston para took a
similar line of attack and accused her
of being a quote for hire escort for Ron
DeSantis
magafan Alex brucevicz referred to her
as quote jeba Ellis before going on to
describe her as a quote d-list reject
goon
so why are all of these hardcore Trump
fans mad at Jenna Ellis
for trying to get a job with Ron
DeSantis
well here's what Jenna Ellis had to say
about that she said I was called a lot
of things and had a lot of less leftist
hit pieces trying to destroy my
credibility while I represented Trump
but I never saw a media Outlet or journo
use the blatant sexism and vulgarity
that Maga influencers do now and I don't
even work for DeSantis she added
so
Jenna Ellis of course has been the
target of you know liberal hit pieces as
she calls them there weren't hit pieces
they were you know talking about your
career and the things you were
attempting to do
now I'm one of those people
I went after Jenna Ellis plenty because
of course she was trying to overturn
a federal election here in the United
States that's definitely not something
that lawyers should be doing especially
based on the fact that all of the
evidence was total BS
never wants to launched a sexist attack
against her never got vulgar with her
just attacked her work
which is fair game
these attacks are disgusting I don't
care if Jenna Ellis is working for
Donald Trump I don't care if she's
working for Ron DeSantis these attacks
are gross and have no place in civilized
discourse here in the United States
especially when the thing they're
accusing her of isn't even a thing at
least not not as of right now
so what's happened
is these crazed Maga fans have created a
fantasy in their heads
right they've created this scenario
where suddenly somehow Jenna Ellis works
for Ron DeSantis
and then they got mad about the fantasy
they created and started attacking her
for doing a thing that they think she
did but she's like I'm not I'm not even
doing it
and honestly who cares if she does
she's not working for Donald Trump
anymore she is a free person in this
country allowed to do whatever the heck
she wants to do if Ron DeSantis wants to
hire her for his campaign as a legal
advisor for a lawyer he's allowed to do
that she's allowed to take it and you
don't get to launch these horrible
attacks against her
if you want to go after her record as a
lawyer if you want to you know critique
the things she says when she goes on you
know a conservative media do it
but once you start to get into that
realm of these disgusting horrendous
attacks that is crossing a line that
these Maga people seem to love to cross
Jenna Ellis was once their friend
but again because they've created this
weird fake scenario now they hate her
they're just going to launch all the
horrible attacks they can
because they think she's doing something
that would be very easy to verify if she
was doing right you you can check the
campaign records you you can check the
state records we do have open records
laws at least at the moment here in
Florida if she were working for Ron
DeSantis it would have to be reported
and you could look that up
but that's a little too much homework
for those Maga folks to do so they would
rather assume the worst
which how is that even the worst
she's not working for Trump she's got to
work somewhere you got to make money
right Republicans always tell you you
got to have a job you can't be a lazy
mooch
so
why are you begrudging somebody for
getting a job
none of it makes any sense
but then again nothing in mega world
makes any sense
and believe it or not that is actually
the message that
presidential candidate Nikki Haley is
also trying to convey to wealthy
Republican donors
it was revealed this week that Nikki
Haley the former ambassador to the UN
former governor of South Carolina
current presidential candidate
sent a memo
to wealthy Republican donors basically
begging them for money
by trashing
both Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump
here's some of what the memo says here's
what the memo says about Trump
it's increasingly clear that Trump's
candidacy is more consumed by the
Grievances of the past and the promise
of more drama in the future rather than
a forward-looking vision for the
American people
no argument there like Nikki Haley your
campaign you hit the nail on the head
no critiques beautifully executed her
attack on Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis
essentially launched his presidential
campaign with a national book tour
during this period and made one misstep
after another confirming what many
observers have long suspected he's not
ready for prime time
again no notes perfect I agree with
every word that you said there
especially because the not ready for
prime time thing is something I have
been saying for the last two years
if anything gets even funnier then she
goes and then there are the others wait
what others
like that's it that's how it ends so
it's beautifully executed again Nikki
Haley top marks for this memo not that I
support you Canada to see
but I gotta say
you said all the right things because
here's what's happening as I said this
is a memo that she sent to wealthy
Republican donors Trump is too much
drama and too much baggage he's in it
for himself get rid of him
Ron DeSantis he's a blithering idiot
that is absolutely bumbling on the
national stage he's got no chance oh
there's some other people maybe but who
are they you don't know them I don't
know them so give me your money
and by the way Nikki Haley
um in the first six weeks of her
campaign raised 11 million dollars
Donald Trump only pulled in I think like
somewhere between six and nine million
in the first quarter of this year now
that doesn't include the massive
fundraising haul that he has had since
the indictment
but had it not been for the indictment
where Trump according to his campaign
raised like 10 million dollars in two
weeks Nikki Haley would be out raising
Donald Trump right now
so Nikki Haley is not a candidate to
just laugh off as another has been
she's actually doing well
not in the polling
you know not where it matters but in the
fundraising Arena she's doing pretty
well you know she's got name recognition
she's traveling and it's been back to
Iowa a couple of times she's going out
there she's doing speeches something
that Trump is not
probably because he's got to worry about
all of his legal problems
but Nikki Haley right now in terms of
being a candidate again please don't
take this as I'm saying I support her or
I like anything she stands for but if we
take off our part of some blinders and
just analyze the campaign itself she's
doing everything right
so this letter attacking her opponents
to the donors that's a smart move
pointing out that she basically raised
more money than Trump is a smart move
she even said at one point like Donald
Trump had a pretty good uh first quarter
if you count being indicted as good
so she's going No Holds Barred right she
is absolutely let's take on Donald Trump
let me bloody him up let me show these
donors that I am the drama-free path
forward I am not out there like Ron
DeSantis looking like an idiot
I'm the real deal that is how she's
pitching herself and again based on her
pitch based on the money that she's
raising
it's pretty obvious that she is doing a
decent job with this
but there is a problem there's a big
problem by the way facing the Republican
party and that problem happens to be
that the largest voting Block in the
United States Millennials and Generation
Z voters
absolutely despise the Republican Party
new data has come out from the 2022
election that tells us
that 77 percent of Generation Z voters
said they voted for a Democratic
candidate for congress last year versus
only 21 percent who said they voted for
a Republican
so we've got a 77 to 21 percent
split between Generation Z voters alone
and of course Millennials maybe not that
extreme but still overwhelmingly vote
for Democrats those two blocks combined
now make up the largest voting Block in
the United States outnumbering the Baby
Boomers which happens to be the largest
voting block for the Republicans
Republicans also have the added I don't
want to call it tragedy but I guess it
is a tragedy of the fact that they let a
lot of their followers and supporters
die
during the pandemic
they were out there trashing vaccines
they were out there telling people ah
you don't have to wear a mask that's
oppression
and they saw a lot of their voters a lot
of their supporters a lot of their core
base die off
because of that
and I think by the way that is a
statistic it's a grim statistic but
that's something that most people
completely ignored during the 2022
midterms I mean I talked about it a lot
because study after study after study
showed us that the coveted death rates
in red areas of the country red counties
were exponentially higher than in blue
counties
that may be one of the reasons why
Republicans who a year ago were
predicting a 70-seat pickup in the house
only have a couple seats in their
majority
I think that's something that needs to
be taken into consideration especially
since we still have people dying in this
country of covid and those deaths are
the overwhelmingly unvaccinated part of
the population
so Republicans have a problem with their
voting block because they're still
letting them die off and then they got a
problem with the young voters who want
nothing to do with the Republican Party
and the reason of course is because
young voters the Millennials and the
Generation Z voters overwhelmingly
support action on gun control
they overwhelmingly support taking
action on the issue of climate change
they overwhelmingly
support lgbtq issues they support access
to abortion they support all of the
things that Republicans have openly
declared war on here in the United
States and what's funny is that the
Republicans have obviously you know
acknowledged this
but here is what Ronald McDaniel the
chair of the Republican National
Committee had to say
when we do when we do that and we talk
about Economic Opportunity the things
our party stands for will win those
voters over
we just have to compete for them
see here's the problem with your plan
Rana first of all it's it's completely
wrong anyway
second of all
you don't have a plan
to pitch to these voters
but you don't have a plan to pitch to
any voters right now the only plans
we're hearing about from the Republican
Party are let's raise the retirement age
for the young people let's make them
just keep working and working and
working and working and Nikki Haley has
that plan she's she said that in a
speech recently republicans in Congress
suggested it like let's just raise the
retirement age
you think that generation that has no
nothing but hardship and Wars based on
lies and pandemics throughout their
whole lives do you think they want to
hear that
but beyond that what is your plan what
is your economic plan Republicans can
anyone watching this tell me what a
republican economic plan is
and tell me who is pushing it and what
it would do for the country anyone
the answer is no you can't because such
a thing doesn't exist
I am 40 years old throughout my lifetime
Republicans
have had one plan other than outside of
culture War stuff I'm talking about one
actual legislative plan my entire life
that one plan has been to cut
taxes
it's been trickle-down economics my
entire life every time Republicans get
power the first thing they want to do is
cut taxes we've already seen the
Republican uh majority in the House of
Representatives propose cutting taxes
again extending the Trump tax cuts
it doesn't work and this generation
knows it this generation isn't afraid to
call it out
they're not buying into those lies of
Reaganomics
and they're angry and as long as
Republicans continue to push that
they will never attract these younger
Generations
we have to take a quick break I'm Farren
cousins again you can subscribe to my
YouTube channels at youtube.com the ring
of fire and youtube.com fair and
balanced and I'm on Twitter Instagram
Tick Tock and Facebook at fair and
balanced we'll be right back with more
on the David Pacman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show welcome
back to the David packman show I am
Faron cousins from Ring of Fire sitting
in for David today and if you want even
more from me you can subscribe to my
YouTube channels youtube.com the ring of
fire and youtube.com fair and balanced
and I also host the ring of fire podcast
every week you can catch that on
rofpodcast.com
Fox News as I'm sure everybody is aware
has a defamation trial coming up and so
far it is not looking good for the right
wing Network late last week it was
announced that they privately settled a
defamation claim brought against them by
Venezuelan businessman uh Majid Khalil
and Khalil had been accused on Lou Dobbs
program by none other than Sydney Powell
herself of running a scheme in Venezuela
he helped allegedly get Hugo Chavez
elected working with those Dominion
voting machines and all that other stuff
and
none of it was true it was in fact a
complete fabrication so Khalil sued for
defamation and last week Fox News
settled
now that lawsuit of course is not
necessarily
as intense as the Dominion voting
systems defamation suit and of course
the other defamation suit filed against
Fox news by smartmatic however some of
the claims with that particular lawsuit
that fox has now settled are also
brought up in Dominion's lawsuit so it's
a big deal especially now Dominion can
go to court and be like look jury
they just settled a lawsuit making the
same claims that we're listing here so
that's kind of them admitting that yeah
it was bad and we'll give you money for
it so I know Fox News wants their legal
problems to go away
but at this stage in the game
if you're going to settle you probably
need to go ahead and settle all of them
that's not a good look for the network
and in a really
really surprising move last week Fox
News also filed a letter with the court
letting them know that they're going to
be offering up certain hosts
to testify at the trial
those hosts include Laura Ingram Sean
Hannity and Tucker Carlson
the three people whose text messages
have been revealed in the court filings
where they talk about how they know what
they're saying is not true they talk
about firing other people from the
Network's producers hosts for
telling the truth I don't know why
Fox News would say hey you want to talk
to these guys under oath on the stand in
front of a jury go for it that seems
like a really really dumb move
I understand in the criminal justice
system
even in the Civil Justice System which
is what this is
sometimes you want the defendant to take
the stand
because they may be able to offer pieces
of evidence or information that might
otherwise not be known right they have
their first-hand accounts they may be
able to convince a jury with their words
that they didn't do whatever it is
they're accused of doing
but in the case of Fox News Hannity
Ingram Carlson and the other hosts that
they have offered up
we have your text messages
we have your emails
there is nothing you can say to justify
that material that is already public
knowledge and that of course will be
brought up in the trial it will be blown
up and shown on big TV screens for the
jury to see
word for word what these people said
all this does and again I'm still
shocked my mind is blown that Fox News
is stupid enough to offer these idiots
up on the stand
all it's going to do is allow the
plaintiff's lawyers to walk up there
point to these statements from somebody
like Tucker Carlson and say tucker what
does this mean you sent this right yes I
sent it did you mean it
well yes I meant it so explain to the
jury what this me that is not going to
end well for Fox like 100 percent
not gonna go their way
and speaking of other things not going
Fox News this way they also recently
tried to prevent Rupert Murdoch from
having to testify at the trial
they argued in front of the judge and
said listen judge Rupert Murdoch he
already sat for hours and hours in the
deposition it's on video that gets shown
during the trial too uh so he doesn't he
doesn't need to come testify plus he's
old traveling is hard for him
and the judge actually ruled against
that saying listen Rupert Murdoch's been
traveling all over the world recently
and now suddenly he's too old to come to
Delaware to testify no I don't buy it
I'm not going to go along with it
also last week with this lawsuit Fox
News went to court and asked the judge
to Bar certain topics from being
discussed at the trial
one of those topics was the capital riot
Fox's lawyer said hey judge we don't
want any discussion during this trial of
the capital Riot no mention of the
capital Riot January 6 basically doesn't
exist
in terms of this trial
oh and also
we want you to ban any mention of the
death threats that Dominion voting
systems employees have received
now to a degree I understand
that the capital Riot really doesn't
have anything to do with the defamation
of Dominion
okay those two are not linked so I get
why you should say we shouldn't talk
about it I just also find it weird that
you specifically want to borrow it makes
me think you got something else up your
sleeve but the death threats against
Dominion employees
that's literally relevant to the case
like that that is a lot of what the case
Hedges on is the harassment that these
workers suffered because of your lies
not to mention as Dominion pointed out
in a counter filing
people don't want to come to work for us
because they're afraid they're going to
get killed because of the lies that
you've spread about our Network so yeah
that hurts our business which falls
under the category of a defamation claim
fox is in trouble
fox is in big trouble are they in
financial trouble not really it's going
to hurt them yeah because they're gonna
end up paying out a lot of money
probably not the total four billion that
the two lawsuits combined are seeking
but they're going to pay out hundreds of
millions of dollars like I I think that
much is pretty much a given at this
point
but the credibility that the network is
suffering
that's going to be almost impossible to
overcome
and what I mean by that is they're not
going to lose the audience they already
have those people are Fox News viewers
they still believe Fox did nothing wrong
those people aren't going anywhere
what they're gonna have trouble with is
when they're very old audience dies off
there's not an audience coming up behind
to replace them
That's The credibility problem
so in the short term Fox will be fine
couple years down the road however
they're going to be in serious trouble
and finally today speaking of serious
trouble how do you feel about going to
war in Mexico not war with Mexico folks
but Republicans
are warming up to the idea of using the
United States military to take on those
nasty drug cartels down in Mexico
let me read you this from Politico
in recent weeks Donald Trump has
discussed sending Special Forces and
using cyber warfare to Target cartel
leaders if he's re-elected president and
per Rolling Stone asked for quote battle
plans to strike Mexico
Representatives Dan Crenshaw and Mike
Waltz both Republicans introduced a bill
seeking authorization for the use of
military force to put us at war with the
cartels Senator Tom Carter Tom Cotton of
Arkansas said he is open to sending U.S
troops into Mexico to Target drug lords
even without that nation's permission
and lawmakers in both Chambers have
filed legislation to label some cartels
as foreign terrorist organizations a
move supported by GOP Presidential
aspirants
so labeling drug cartels
as uh
uh terrorist organizations basically
gives the government a lot more leeway
to send in U.S troops without of course
having to go through getting all that
authorization from Congress officially
declaring war if we can just slap a
broad label on them
we can kind of kill whoever we want to
kill
and that is unfortunately the way that
our government is set up in a post-9 11
world
here's the thing
this really isn't about the drugs
it's not believe it or not it's not
about the drugs what this is about
is being able
to bomb a Sovereign Nation
to shoot whoever we want to shoot down
in Mexico by claiming
they're a drug Smuggler
now imagine if you will a caravan let's
call it a caravan of people approaching
our Southern border
and then folks on Fox News and
Republican politicians and candidates
tell us we know a lot of these people
are are smuggling drugs
suddenly
you're able to apply that terrorist
label
to these so-called Caravans
and you can send one missile
you send a drone down there to take them
out
that's what this is about
it's not about the drugs folks it is not
about the drugs
it is about getting that label so that
they can use the military force
so that they can attack migrants so that
they can attack Asylum Seekers all by
claiming nope they had drugs they were
smuggling drugs we'll never know
right I mean we'll never be able to
fully find out if they did or didn't
have drugs
and that's the plan that's what this is
about
this is about a show of force
on our Southern border not deep in
Mexico but on our Southern border giving
the United States the Republican Party
the ability to kill anybody that they
don't want in this country
that's all the time we have for today
but we've got a great bonus show coming
up for you I am fair and cousins from
ring of fire thank you so much for
watching today I'll see you again
tomorrow